- With Encanto you celebrated
the Hispanic family
and generational trauma
was kind of a major theme.
- Yeah. Well, it's funny.
I remember talking to you,
I think the week before it came out.
- Dude, I love you so much.
You're so talented.
I don't think you know a person
that's seen that movie more
than myself because of my kids.
(Lynn and audience laughing)
- I remember the week
before it came out also,
I did your show and I met
someone and his name was Bruno,
and I said, "You're not
gonna understand this yet,
(Kelly and audience laughing)
but I'm so sorry.
I'm just- just remember I
said, I'm sorry in advance."
- [Kelly] It's like any girl named Jolene?
(audience laughing)
- Yeah. Jolenes
or Brunos,
- Or Felicia.
Elisas, I am sorry.
(Kelly laughing)
- I love that. That's hysterical.
But speaking of Encanto,
is it true that Bruno
originally had a different name?
- Yeah. Bruno in the early
drafts was named Oscar.
- [Kelly] I can't hear that now.
- Yeah well-
♪ You don't talk about Oscar ♪
♪ Car, car, car ♪
- [Lynn] It doesn't sing.
- [Kelly] It's yeah- Bruno sounds good.
- [Lynn] And then they found
out that Oscar Madrigal
was like a super common name
or like a taken name in Colombia.
And so they gave me like
three other finalists.
And as soon as I saw
Bruno, I was like, got it.
- Yeah.
- I got the whole song.
- I got Bruno and I can
play with the no, no, no.
And I'm done.
Thank you for writing-
- Great vowel.
- the song for me. Great vowel.
- Just a great vowel to sing, really.
- Yeah
- I like to change those up
sometimes and they're like
that's not how you pronounce it.
I don't care.